je viens cet après midi à cette tribune
soutenir une proposition de loi que j'ai
déposée et qui porte évidemment sur le
fait de renforcer le suivi des condamnés
terroriste sortant de détention dans les
prochaines années nous savons que plus
de 500 détenus condamnés pour faits en
lien avec le terrorisme islamiste ihh à
dist sortiront de prison
face à ce risque le parlement a adopté
le 27 juillet dernier à la suite
d'initiatives convergentes à la fois du
sénat et de l'assemblée nationale la loi
instaurant des mesures de sûreté à
l'encontre des auteurs d'infractions
terroristes à l'issue de leur peine
compte tenu de la particulière
dangerosité et du risque élevé de
récidive
une fois leur peine d'emprisonnement
accompli nous avions jugé nécessaire que
des mesures de surveillance adaptée
puisse être que puisse leur être
appliquée après leur sortie de détention
dans sa décision du 7 août 2020 le
conseil constitutionnel n'a pas remis en
cause le principe même d'une mesure de
sûreté à l'égard des deux condamnés
terroristes ayant purgé leur peine
mais en dépit de nombreuses garanties
que nous avions prévu le nous étant le
législateur il a considéré que le
dispositif retenu portait une atteinte
qui n'était ni adaptée ni proportionnée
aux droits et libertés
constitutionnellement garantis malgré
cette appréciation du juge
constitutionnel demeure malgré tout
l'impérieuse nécessité d'un dispositif
permettant d'assurer le suivi de
personnes qui libérés à l'issue de leur
peine peuvent continuer à constituer une
grave menace pour la sécurité publique
les mesures de police administrative
plus connu sous l'acronyme de me casse
aujourd'hui privilégiée n'offrent pas au
regard de
durée un cadre de surveillance suffisant
le renforcement des dispositifs de suivi
judiciaire apparaît en conséquence comme
la voix juridiquement la plus adaptée
pour répondre à l'enjeu que représente
en terme de sécurité publique
la sortie de détention des condamnés
terroristes tout en offrant des
garanties de réinsertion renforcer dans
cette perspective la présente
proposition de loi prend acte de la
décision du conseil constitutionnel
reprend le principe du dispositif adopté
en juillet 2020 celui d'un suivi
judiciaire prononcée au stade poste
sentenciel d'une durée décorrélé des
crédits de réduction de peine est
conditionnée à une évaluation
pluridisciplinaire de dangerosité
apprécié en fin de peine
tout en y apportant les aménagements
destinés à le rendre pleinement
compatible avec les outils de cette
déceler motifs de cette décision
ainsi en premier lieu son article unique
réduit la durée maximale de la mesure de
sûreté en la fixant à 3 ans au lieu de
cinq pour les personnes condamnées à
moins de 10 ans d'emprisonnement et à 5
ans au lieu de 10 au delà seraient
également maintenus une atténuation en
cas de minorités avec des durée ne
pouvant excéder respectivement deux et
trois ans il fixe en août cet article la
durée maximale de la mesure en fonction
du quantum de la peine effectivement
prononcées et non pas en fonction de la
peine encourue
en deuxième lieu le texte propose enfin
proposé exclu l'application de la mesure
de sûreté aux personnes condamnées à une
peine d'emprisonnement assortis d'un
sursis probatoire il imite ailleurs par
ailleurs le cumul de la mesure de sûreté
à une
assortie d'un sursis simple en troisième
lieu le texte propose proposée prévoit
que la mesure ne pourra être prononcée
ne pourra être prononcée par don que
lorsque la personne a été mis en mesure
de suivre un programme de réinsertion en
détention
à l'instar d'autres mesures de
surveillance judiciaire existant en
quatrième lieu même si cette précision
été sous-entendu dans la rédaction
adoptée par le parlement lille dispose
explicitement que le renouvellement de
la mesure ne pourra être prononcée qu'à
l'issue d'une évaluation établissant la
dangerosité sur la base d'éléments
actuelle et circonstances et enfin enfin
la proposition de loi introduit une
gradation dont le prononcé des
obligations susceptibles est imposé à la
personne sortant de détention afin de
garantir que deux seront prononcées que
les obligations strictement nécessaires
et proportionnées à sa situation
personnelle
ainsi dans le cadre du dispositif prévu
la juridiction pourra imposer aux
personnes concernées le suivi d'un
certain nombre d'obligations qui sont
déjà applicables dans le cadre d'autres
mesures de suivi judiciaire et qui
relève pour la plupart d'entre elles
d'un suivi social et d'un accompagnement
personnalisé à la réinsertion
en revanche le prononcé des obligations
les plus attentatoires aux libertés
individuelles les obligation de pointage
l'interdiction de paraître dans certains
lieux et l'interdiction de fréquenter
certaines personnes seront réservés aux
personnes pour lesquelles les premières
obligations se révélera insuffisante
compte tenu de leur situation de leur
personnalité ou de leur niveau de
dangerosité
je voudrais vous indiquez simplement que
l'objectif de cette proposition est
naturellement de de tentes et de
réaffirmer et de redire et de remettre
en place une procédure est un dispositif
qui avait été souhaitée par le sénat et
par l'assemblée nationale
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que nous devons tenir compte évidemment
de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel
naturellement nous essayons par ce texte
de nous caler sur ce concept l'addition
du conseil constitution
la troisième chose c'est que lorsqu'un
détenu sort de détention qu'il a purgé
sa peine car il faut bien comprendre que
nous sommes dans le cas où le détenu a
purgé sa peine on peut installer des
mesures administratives c'est que les me
casser ce qui se passe elles sont
limitées à ce jour dans le temps à une
année mais dès lors que l'on veut
contrôler plus longtemps et de façon
plus j'allais dire contraignantes
nous devons impérativement passer par la
voie judiciaire
car c'est le juge qui décidera est ce
lui seul qui peut décider de mesures
contraignantes poste sentenciel et
surtout après avoir après qu'est la
peine a été exécuté toute la discussion
en réalité est là mais rien n'empêche
que les deux mesures peuvent puisse se
cumuler pendant une certaine période
d'ailleurs et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons à proposer cette ce
texte
en espérant naturellement qu'il recevra
votre approbation
je vous remercie merci président j
invite maintenant madame muriel jourda
rapporteur de la commission des lois à
s'exprimer pour un poids équivalent de
10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mes chers collègues
vous avez ceux ci que la proposition de
loi de présidente du fait a pour but de
répondre à un enjeu de sécurité publique
majeur qui est la sortie de détention
des terroristes qui présenteraient
toujours un caractère de dangerosité
ce n'est pas qu'une question théorique
c'est une question qui va se poser avec
une certaine acuité aujourd'hui existe
en détention 469 personnes dont 253 sont
condamnées définitivement pour des faits
en lien avec le terrorisme 162 vont
sortir dans les quatre prochaines années
évidemment ainsi que l'a expliqué le
président du fer notre arsenal juridique
n'est pas dépourvue de moyens pour
suivre les personnes qui aujourd'hui
sorte de détention en présentant
toujours un caractère de dangerosité
s'agissant du terrorisme qui on le sait
aujourd'hui en france et le terrorisme
islamiste
il existe un certain nombre de mesures
je vais vous en brossé un rapide tableau
pour se rendre compte des raisons pour
lesquelles ces mesures sont
insuffisantes et pour envisager à quel
point ce texte est aujourd'hui elle
nécessaire la première mesure qui existe
est une mesure administrative mesures
individuelles de contrôle
administratives et de surveillance qu'on
a coutume d'appeler la me casse depuis
la loi sécurité intérieure à but contre
le terrorisme autrement appelée la loi
sylt c'est une mesure qui est
intéressante qui offrent évidemment des
obligations des obligations de
surveillance à l'égard de ces personnes
qui sortent de détention mais c'est une
mesure administrative prononcée à
l'initiative du ministère de l'intérieur
et de ce fait cette mesure qui est
attentatoire aux libertés individuelles
ne peut être prononcée que dans un cadre
extrêmement restrictif il s'agit
notamment du fait qu' elle ne peut
excéder une durée de 12 mois et c'est
précisément cette durée réduite qui a
permis au conseil constitutionnel de
valider cette mesure lorsque la loi s'il
a été soumise à la censure du conseil
constitutionnel
une mesure intéressante mais une mesure
trop courte pour permettre à suivi
raisonnable il existe également une
peine une peine qu'on appelle peine de
suivi socio-judiciaire mesures
intéressantes aussi qui peut être
prononcée en même temps qu'est condamné
l'auteur de faits en lien avec le
terrorisme et qui n'est malheureusement
obligatoire que depuis le mois d'août
2020 de sorte qu'elle était jusqu'à lors
peut prononcer
d'autres mesures existent qui sont des
mesures d'application des peines qui
offre également un panel des obligations
qui peuvent s'imposer aux terroristes
qui sort de prison
mais la durée de ces mesures est calquée
sur la réduction de peine or depuis
juillet 2007
nous avons décidé que la réduction des
peines et bien automatique était
supprimée pour les personnes qui avaient
commis une infraction aux liens que le
terrorisme ne sorte que la durée de ces
mesures est également extrêmement
réduite puisqu'elle est calquée sur la
réduction des peines prononcées par le
juge et non pas automatiquement prévue
par le code pénal
d'autres mesures de sûreté existe
également qu'ils sont destinés aussi à
s'imposer à la personne qui sort de
prison mais celles ci ont été plus
particulièrement prévu pour les
délinquants sexuels
elle concerne donc les peines longues et
la dangerosité de l'individu est
apprécié par une expertise psychiatrique
or ce n'est pas la façon d'apprécier la
dangerosité des terroristes islamistes
donc elles n'ont pas une grande utilité
pour le sujet qui nous concerne et enfin
et c'est la seule mesure qui existe pour
faire face au terrorisme islamiste
il s'agit de l'inscription au fise est
le fichier
informatiser judiciaire des auteurs
d'infractions terroriste mesures
intéressantes mais assez faible qui
prévoit l'inscription officielle d'un
certain nombre d'obligations qui sont
essentiellement déclaratif donc nous
avons vous le voyez des mesures diverses
administratives et judiciaires qui
existent mais lorsque l'on se penche sur
ces mesures
on constate que pour les faits qui ont
été commis entre juillet 2016 c'est à
dire la date à laquelle les suivis
étaient calqués qui était calquée sur la
durée de réduction des peines de vienne
extrêmement bref puisque nous n'avons
plus de reddition traduction automatique
des pelles à compter de juin 2016
jusqu'à août 2020 ou là enfin un suivi
socio judiciaire peut être prononcée et
va être efficace est devenu obligatoire
sur ce laps de temps qui est tout de
même relativement long et bien sûr ces
apps de temps nous disposons que de peu
de moyens et d'ailleurs sur les
personnes qui sont actuellement suivis
pour des faits en lien avec le
terrorisme islamiste par le juge
d'application des peines antiterroriste
75 % de celles qu'ils vont sortir ne
vont sortir qu'avec une capacité de
suivi calquée sur la réduction des
peines dont je viens de vous indiquer
qu'elles étaient relativement faibles
donc malgré l'arsenal qui existe nous
avons besoin de nouvelles mesures
cette prise de conscience est
relativement ancienne si je puis le dire
puisque après que la loi s'il t'a fait
l'objet d'une évaluation à la fois par
le sénat mais également par l'assemblée
nationale est ainsi que l'indiqué le
président du fai
chaque président de la commission des
lois a déposé dans chaque assemblée
une proposition de loi destinée à mettre
en oeuvre une mesure de sûreté mesures
de sûreté qui prévoit pour les
terroristes islamistes qui sortent de
détention à la fois des obligations qui
sont liés à des mesures de surveillance
et à la fois des obligations qui sont
liées à la réinsertion
cette mesure de sûreté fonctionne sur
ces deux piliers surveillance
réinsertion nous avons trouvé un accord
une commission mixte paritaire a eu lieu
un texte a été voté en juillet 2020 qui
était partiellement invalidés par le
conseil constitutionnel
et c'est pour ce motif que nous
trouvons aujourd'hui devant vous pour
tirer les conséquences de la décision du
conseil constitutionnel
que nous dit le conseil constitutionnel
il nous dit des choses tout à fait
positive dans un premier temps tout
d'abord que sans paraphraser totalement
le conseil constitutionnel cité mais
sans je crois trahir à l'esprit de ce
qui a été dit le législateur est
légitime à mettre en oeuvre une mesure
qui est de nature à prévenir les
troubles à l'ordre public et il est
légitime à ce titre a prononcé a décidé
plutôt d'une mesure de sûreté
la mesure de sûreté est une mesure qui
n'est pas fondée sur l'infraction
commise mais bien sûr la dangerosité
persistante de la personne qui sort de
prison
ce serait autrement et le président du
fel est très bien expliqué une double
peine
donc nous savons d'ores et déjà que la
mesure que nous allons prendre à bien le
caractère d'une mesure de sûreté ce qui
est extrêmement important car la double
peine nous n'aurions pas pu et la mesure
de sûreté est d'application immédiate
il peut donc s'appliquer à ceux de ces
détenus pour terrorisme qui vont sortir
de prison immédiatement
c'est donc un élément important que nous
apporter le conseil constitutionnel est
positif ce qui a été moins positif pour
le texte qui est sorti de nous deux
assemblées la commission mixte paritaire
et que le conseil constitutionnel a
estimé que la balance n'étaient pas
faites et correctement équilibré entre
eux
la prévention des troubles à l'ordre
public qui est un objectif à valeur
constitutionnelle et l'atteinte aux
libertés constitutionnellement reconnus
c'est donc sur ces éléments qu'il a
fallu se pencher pour rééquilibrer ce
texte
c'est ce qu'a fait le président buffet
j'indiquerai que la commission des lois
n'a que très peu modifié cette
proposition de loi qui paraissait
répondre en tout point à ce que le
conseil constitutionnel avait pu décider
et à la censure qui avaient été faites
de sorte que la mesure de sûreté qui je
le rappelle est une mesure de
surveillance et de réinsertion se
présente de la façon suivante
une évaluation est faite du détenu avant
sa sortie de détention sur requête du
parquet antiterroriste une juridiction
qui est une juridiction parisienne
juridiction des mesures de rétention de
sûreté est saisie l'avis du juge
d'application des peines antiterroriste
est requis un débat lieux contradictoire
le détenu est assisté d'un avocat une
décision est prise
la mesure de sûreté ne peut pas être
prononcée si le détenu n'a pas pu suivre
un parcours de réinsertion des activités
de réinsertion en prison la mesure ne
peut pas être prononcé non plus si le
détenu a été condamné et a fait l'objet
d'une condamnation à une peine de prison
avec sursis
elle ne sera pas non plus prononcée ou
en tout cas elle pourra être réformé
si il existe d'autres mesures moins
attentatoires qui vont permettre
d'atteindre l'objectif de surveillance
et de réinsertion qui est poursuivi
cette mesure sera prononcée pour une
durée limitée de 3 à 5 ans maximum et
toutes les mesures qui existent ne
pourront être présentés ensemble
il conviendra de mettre en oeuvre la
gradation dont on vous a parlé tout à
l'heure le président buffet système dont
ils et dont il est l'auteur en d'autres
termes plus le détenu sera dangereux la
sortie et plus les mesures qui lui
seront posées seront importantes ce qui
paraît d'une grande logique et enfin
ceux cette proposition loi permettra
aussi d'inscrire au fichier des
personnes recherchées différentes
obligations qui sont imposés à la
personne détenue qui sort de prison
donc voilà brossé à grands traits
qu'elle est larchitecture de cette
nouvelle mesure dont nous espérons
qu'elle aura à cette fois ci les faveurs
du conseil constitutionnel
je vous remercie merci madame le
rapporteur j'invite maintenant eric
dupond-moretti notre garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice intervenir
ce ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame la rapporteure mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la proposition
de loi dont nous débattons aujourd'hui
va bien sûr dans le bon sens et je veux
souligner madame la rapporteure monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
la qualité de votre réflexion et de
votre travail
cette proposition de loi s'inscrit
pleinement dans l'objectif que s'est
fixé le gouvernement
celui de réduire au maximum une menace
nouvelle une menace terrifiante la
possible récidive des personnes
condamnées pour des actes de terrorisme
qui présenteraient encore alors que leur
peine arrive à terme des signes de
dangerosité depuis 2010 est la lutte
contre le terrorisme et la priorité de
ce gouvernement il a d'ailleurs déployé
à cette fin des moyens sans précédent
pour renforcer la réponse de nos
services de sécurité équipées la justice
de tous les outils nécessaires au
traitement de cette menace nous rappeler
la création de dix mille postes
supplémentaires de gendarmes de
policiers l'augmentation du budget la
création du parc national antiterroriste
l'augmentation du nombre de quartiers
d'évaluation de la radicalisation
l'augmentation du personnel affecté aux
renseignements pénitentiaire je tiens
également à rappeler que depuis 2010 est
ce sont trente six attentats terroristes
liés à la mouvance islamiste qui ont été
déjouées par nos services de
renseignement j'ai à cet instant
évidemment une pensée à prier pour
toutes les victimes des actes de
terrorisme qui ont endeuillé notre pays
cette impérieuse nécessité d'agir face à
cette nouvelle menace s'inscrit dans un
contexte que je souhaite comme vous
monsieur le président madame la reporter
rappeler un instant
d'ici la fin de l'année 2024 163
personnes actuellement détenues pour
acte de terrorisme en lien avec la
mouvance islamiste auront purgé leur
peine
or certaines de ces personnes présentes
et présenteront sans doute encore des
signes de radicalisation
al'approche de cette échéance depuis
2016 le régime d'aménagement de peines
en matière de terrorisme a été durcie
afin de répondre à la crainte que des
personnes radicaliser potentiellement
dangereuses soit remise en liberté alors
que la france à fond une effroyable
série d'actions terroristes
aujourd'hui ce sont précisément ces
mêmes détenus pour la sortie ne peut
plus être aménagés qui s'apprête à
quitter la détention
or un certain nombre d'entre eux et
qu'ils ne pourront bénéficier d'une
mesure de surveillance judiciaire seront
libérés ont sorties sèches
selon l'expression convenue s'ensuivit
ni accompagnement
je tiens ici à saluer avec force
l'important travail réalisé dans nos
établissements pénitentiaires afin de
prévenir la radicalisation des détenus
et de frais d tout prosélytisme délétère
les services de mon ministère
travaillent sans répit pour améliorer
l'évaluation de la prise en charge des
personnes condamnées ou qui présentent
des signes de pour terrorisme ou qui
présentent des signes de radicalisation
c'est les tenues sont aujourd'hui
évaluées
durant seize semaines dans les quartiers
d'évaluation de la radicalisation plus
connu sous l'acronyme qr nous disposons
de 121 une place au plan national
et un quartier réservé aux femmes un
casse et ouvrira fin 2021 au centre
pénitentiaire de fresnes par ailleurs
nous disposons de 188 places de quartier
de prise en charge de la radicalisation
au plan national les détenus évaluer
comment capacité de se soumettre à une
prise en charge
il bénéficie de programme de
désengagements grâce à l'intervention
d'une équipe pluridisciplinaire composée
d'un médiateur du fait religieux de
psychologues de personnels
pénitentiaires un quartier de ce type
réservé aux femmes détenues ouvrira
cette fois dans le courant de l'été 2021
au centre pénitentiaire de rennes
enfin le service du renseignement
pénitentiaire dont nous avons augmenté
les effectifs de 100 personnels en trois
ans assure un suivi très poussée des
condamnés à leur libération
en lien bien sûr très étroit avec les
services partenaires du renseignement
vous le savez car c'est un constat
partagé la remise en liberté de détenus
condamnés pour des faits de nature
terroriste potentiellement toujours
radicaliser en dépit du travail réalisé
appelle une réponse forte et efficace
car il est notre devoir de tout mettre
en oeuvre pour garantir dans le respect
de notre état de droit
bien sûr la sécurité de nos concitoyens
le gouvernement s'est déjà attaché dans
le cadre du dispositif issu de la loi
sylt du 30 octobre 2017 qui a ouvert la
possibilité de soumettre les sortants à
une mesure de contrôle administratif et
de surveillance le projet de loi relatif
à la prévention d'actes de terrorisme et
au renseignement dit s'il te 2
actuellement en débat à l'assemblée
nationale
d'ailleurs voté jeudi en commission des
lois et dont votre assemblée aura sera
prochainement saisi prévoit ainsi de
pérenniser ces mesures administratives
qui ont fait là
eux ils réfutable de leur efficacité
pour autant les conditions de la
soumission à un nouveau régime
judiciaire restrictif de liberté des
personnes qui ont déjà purgé leur peine
doit appeler à la plus grande vigilance
c'est le sens de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel rendue en août dernier
concernant la proposition de loi
établissements établissant pardon des
mesures de sûreté pour les auteurs
d'infractions terroristes nul besoin de
rappeler que cette ppl s'inscrivait déjà
dans la volonté commune qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui d'apporter une solution à la
nouvelle menace des sortants de prison
condamné pour terrorisme
si le travail de réécriture au sénat à
la suite de cette censure doit être
salué il ne nous paraît pas suffisant
pour parer à toutes les critiques alors
formulé par le conseil constitutionnel
ne saurait en effet être question
d'instaurer ou de laisser penser que
nous sommes prêtes à instaurer une
quelconque forme de justice prédictive
qui est la négation même de l'idée de
justice puisqu'elle revient à condamner
sur un simple soupçon le respect de nos
valeurs impose à mon sens que le régime
applicable aux détenus terroristes
neutralisent leur éventuelle dangerosité
et c'est à l'aune de ces considérations
que le gouvernement souhaite la création
dans le projet de loi relatif à la
prévention d'actes de terrorisme ou au
renseignement d'une mesure judiciaire de
prévention de la récidive terroristes
cette mesure permettra d'assujettir le
condamner un suivi au moyen
d'obligations et d'interdictions à
vocation essentiellement sociales
le projet porté par le gouvernement qui
arrivera très prochainement au sénat
assure l'articulation entre le
dispositif administratif la surveillance
et le dispositif judy
la proposition de loi du président
buffet que nous examinons aujourd'hui on
sait qu'elle prévoit la création d'une
mesure de sûreté judiciaire poursuit
certes des objectifs comparables
toutefois certaines des obligations et
interdictions auxquelles peuvent être
astreintes
les personnes concernées sont similaires
ou voisines de celles prévues par les me
casse comme par exemple l'interdiction
paraître dans certains lieux ou de
fréquenter certaines personnes une telle
superposition apparaît de nature à
fragiliser selon nous la légalité des me
casse prononcée à l'encontre des mêmes
personnes alors même que ces mesures
permettent le prononcer d'obligations
plus rigoureuse encore d'une manière
générale le gouvernement considère que
la superposition de dispositifs de
sûreté différents sous la responsabilité
des autorités différentes si ces petits
bleus d'être appliquée à des mêmes fins
et aux mêmes personnes en prévoyant des
prescriptions similaires ou identiques
créer une complexité qui nuit à l'action
de l'état prise dans ses fonctions
administratives et judiciaires
enfin il convient de rappeler que les
mesures de sûreté doivent respecter le
principe résultant de l'article 9 de la
déclaration de 1789 selon lequel la
liberté ne saurait être entravée par une
rigueur qui ne serait pas nécessaire il
incombe au législateur d'assurer la
conciliation entre d'une part la
prévention des atteintes à l'ordre
public nécessaire à la sauvegarde de
droit et de principes de valeur
constitutionnelle et d'autre part
l'exercice des libertés
constitutionnellement garantis comme je
lai indiqué le conseil constitutionnel
dans sa décision du 7 ou 2020 est venue
rappeler la vigilance qui doit être
celle
législateur sur le caractère adapté
nécessaire et proportionné de mesures
restrictives de liberté
lorsqu'elles sont imposés à des
personnes ayant purgé leur peine
or précisément certaines des
dispositions de cette proposition de loi
en particulier les conditions de
renouvellement de la mesure de sûreté ne
semble pas répondre aux exigences
constitutionnelles rappelé par le
conseil constitutionnel dans cette
décision
17 août dernier et laisse craindre une
nouvelle censure qui doit absolument
être évités pour qu'enfin enfin puisse
être mise en place le nécessaire suivi
les sortants de prison condamné pour
terrorisme
vous savez nous sommes juridiquement sur
une ligne de crête il appartient à 6 au
législateur de prendre des mesures qui
permettent d'assurer la protection des
français tout en veillant à ne pas
adopter des mesures qui ne seraient pas
strictement nécessaires
c'est cette proposition qu'a formulé le
gouvernement dans son article 5 de loups
à sylt qui arrivera le mois prochain
dans cet hémicycle
en conclusion je ne peux mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que saluer
l'objectif poursuivi par cette
proposition de loi en ce qu'il rejoint
l'engagement du gouvernement dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme est confiant
la détermination du sénat en la matière
en lui préférant toutefois la version
gouvernementale qui vous sera proposé
prochainement et qui sera je le crois
plus à même de répondre aux exigences
constitutionnelles désormais clairement
établie je donne maintenant la parole à
monsieur alain richard pour le groupe f
des pays mêmes vous avez six minutes
chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
franchissons une nouvelle à nouvel
épisode de l'histoire d'une adaptation
de notre droit pénal à une criminalité
particulière c'est une histoire à
épisodes avec l'aggravation de la
criminalité terroristes qui commence en
2012 dans notre prix est bien vite dans
le reste de l'europe
notre législation se renforce à la fois
pour mieux caractériser et rendre
punissable les crimes et délits qui
constituent ce mouvement pour adapter
aussi les procédures en prévenant les
risques de prolongation excessive des
jugements et aussi il faut bien dire le
risque d' intimidation de ceux qui
instruisent écusson de ceux qui
sanctionnent des effets de ce droit
raynaud les deux combats du terrorisme
sont maintenant à l'oeuvre et le moment
est opportun pour affirmer notre respect
et notre soutien à tous les agents
publics qui le met en oeuvre
d'abord les magistrats les policiers et
agents des services
le personnel pénitentiaire et celui des
services de probation
mais à mesure que ce dispositif
répressif s'est déployé un problème est
apparu qui surplombe notre discussion
d'aujourd'hui
l' idéologie meurtrière qui a conduit à
l'acte terroriste notamment dior pour
ceux qui sont sanctionnés pour
complicité ne disparaît pas avec
l'exécution de la peine
depuis 4 ou 5 ans se développe donc une
discussion sur la déradicalisation pu
d'ailleurs notre collègue esther
benbassa a analysé de façon très juste à
l'instant à cette tribune
c'est 7
procédure de l'hérétique
déradicalisation présente un réel
intérêt mais ne conclut pas le sujet des
anciens condamnés car ceux-ci ne
présentent pas tous loin s'en faut
la disponibilité mentale et la capacité
le retour dans la norme qui en est la
première condition
il subsiste donc une dangerosité des
anciens condamnés qui nous adressent une
sorte de double défi rester fidèle aux
principes d'une justice humaniste écarté
la mesure vite la menace vitale
d'individus restant enclin à combattre
la société par le meurtre nous avons
adopté le 27 juillet de l'année dernière
une loi qui habilitait le juge à prendre
après l'exécution de la peine un
ensemble de mesures de sûreté à
l'encontre des anciens condamnés pour
terrorisme dans le but de prévenir et
déjà de détecter les agissements qui
révélerait leur tendance à vouloir à
nouveau a tenté au sort de nos
concitoyens le conseil constitutionnel a
déclaré cet ensemble de mesures comme
contraire aux articles de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme qui protège la
liberté individuelle contre les
sentences abusive
il a critiqué si on regarde de près sa
rédaction sa motivation
le cumul de mesures aboutissants si on
les applique tout appris mais l'individu
d'une part essentielle de sa liberté et
le conseil constitutionnel également
critiqué la durée maximale d'application
de ces mesures de sûreté qui peuvent
faire procès qui pouvaient en effet dans
la loi de juillet 2020 poursuivre leur
effet sur une période pouvant aller
jusqu'à 10 ans pourtant cette loi avait
l'approbation de nos deux assemblées par
une majorité assez large dans les deux
cas après un travail approfondi de nos
deux comme sur des lois et beaucoup
d'entre nous nous y sommes associés
et je m'étais personnellement réjouis de
vous entendre monsieur le garde des
sceaux
peu après votre entrée en fonction
apportez votre appui à ce dispositif
à présent ils font reprendre la plume
puisque d'une part le risque à combattre
est toujours aussi présent et que notre
part le conseil constitutionnel a au
moins reconnu et j'appelle aussi votre
attention monsieur ministre sur ce point
au moins reconnu la conformité au droit
de l'adoption de mesures individuelles
de sûreté en pareille situation il est
donc souhaitable d'adapter un système de
suivi son contrôle du juge judiciaire et
d'une rigueur ou insérés que la panoplie
trop large que nous avions fixé l'été
dernier et observons que le précédent
démesure la plus comparable impliqués
ont dû aux anciens délinquants sexuels
condamnés est lui jugé parfaitement
conforme aux principes supérieurs du
droit la proposition de loi du président
buffet retient donc et cela s'appuie sur
la logique normal de donner suite de la
décision du conseil le les trois
principales mesures de contrainte qui
était incluse dans leur l'ensemble plus
vaste de 2020 à savoir l'obligation de
faire connaître son lieu de résidence
l'interdiction de paraître dans certains
lieux et l'interdiction d'entrer en
contact avec certains individus
dispositif qui figurent dans le code
pénal de longue date et qui s'appliquent
à les quantités de situation la durée
cette fois ci est plus limité et chaque
mesure est décidée par un juge
judiciaire après application du droit de
la défense
nous trouvons donc ce dispositif
équilibré et adapté aux dangers qu'il
faut combattre et nous espérons
rationnellement qui ne sera cette fois
ci conclut il est conforme aux exigences
supérieures du droit nous savons que le
gouvernement de son côté a en
préparation une réponse légale a suivi
alice lation nous pouvons laisser
subsister et nous souhaitons vivement
que le rapprochement se fasse entre les
deux approches comme ç'avait été le cas
dans le débat précédent donc il faut
veiller où l'avait dit monsieur le garde
des sceaux aux ailes aux risques du
cumul entre les mesures administratives
de contrôle et des mesures judiciaires
mais nous pensons qu'il faut poursuivre
le débat et je vous permettra d'assister
monsieur le garde des sceaux pour que la
fin de la préparation du projet de loi
vous incorporez y est certaine au moins
des mesures qui sont prévus dans la
proposition du président du fai et que
vous de mardi au conseil d'état
d'apprécier la compatibilité de
l'ensemble des mesures celles que vous
avez en projet et celles qui sont
délibérées aujourd'hui dans ces
conditions nous freinons que le débat se
poursuivre et nous adresserons à se
voiler loi une abstention compréhensive
merci chers collègues
j'appelle à présent madame maryse
carrère à s'exprimer au nom du groupe
rdse pour cinq minutes cher collègue
madame la présidente monsieur ministre
madame la rapporteure monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
les chiffres avancés suscite une vive
inquiétude presque 500 personnes
seraient détenues en france pour des
actes de terrorisme en lien avec la
mouvance islamiste
parmi lesquelles un nombre significatif
devrait sortir de détention ces
prochaines années notre société fait
donc face à un double défi
d'abord celui de la réinsertion
d'individus ayant déjà fait acte de leur
dangerosité de leur radicalité et du
rejet de notre société
ensuite celui de parvenir à les
réinsérer sans renier la philosophie de
notre état de droit
laquelle ne doit d'aucune manière à
transiger et céder sur le respect des
libertés fondamentales
notre parlement et donc adopté le 27
juillet 2020 la loi sylt proposant un
dispositif de suivi
et de surveillance post en ciel pour les
individus condamnés pour des faits de
terrorisme à leur sortie de détention il
a été rappelé les motifs pour lesquels
le conseil constitutionnel a été
contraint d'en censurer d un site d
éléments principaux considérant qu'en
l'état il était imposé des obligations
interdictions portant une atteinte trop
importante à la liberté d'aller et de
venir au droit au respect de la vie
privée et au droit de mener une vie
familiale normale
toutefois nous nous réjouissons que le
conseil n'est pas rejeté le principe de
la mise en place de cette mesure
ils nous reviennent donc de trouver
l'équilibré et la justesse qui
permettront à ce mécanisme d'être
définitivement adopté dans le respect de
nos principes essentiels et tout en
conservant l'espoir d'une efficacité en
vue de la réinsertion des personnes
condamnées pour des actes de terrorisme
aussi les ajustements proposés par les
auteurs de cette proposition de loi
paraissent de nature à satisfaire ses
diverses exigences qu'il s'agisse de la
durée de la mesure où bien de
l'encadrement des possibilités de cumul
avec les mesures de sursis
ces éléments devraient permettre aux
dispositifs de passer le stade du
contrôle de constitutionnalité et donc
d'entrer en vigueur le plus tôt possible
de la même façon je veux saluer des
ajustements répondant à la nécessité d'
éléments nouveaux et complémentaires
pour le renouvellement de la mesure de
suivi la censure constitutionnelle aura
ainsi permis d'introduire une nouvelle
évaluation établissant la dangerosité
sur la base d'éléments actuelle et
circonstanciée il en va de même de la
gradation introduite dans le prononcé
des obligations susceptibles d'être
imposées
j'ai l'espoir à l'image de la position
de notre commission des lois que la
réponse apportée par cette proposition
de loi soit de nature à permettre la
constitutionnalité du dispositif lequel
tiendra mieux compte de compte tenu de
la situation de la personnalité ou du
niveau de dangerosité de la personne
visée par la mesure
j'aimerais enfin souligner un point en
particulier cette proposition intègre le
principe suivant lequel la mesure de
sûreté ne peut intervenir
à l'issue de l'exécution d'une peine
d'emprisonnement que si la personne a pu
pendant l'exécution de cette peine
bénéficier de mesures de nature à
favoriser sa réinsertion
cela est évidemment le bienvenu et nous
abordons la un point fondamental celui
du rôle de l'institution carcérale dans
notre société
en effet je crains qu'il faille y voir
ici l'aveu d'une forme d'échec
certes la prison punis mais elle ne
prépare pas suffisamment à sa sortie
elle joue son rôle de répression mais ne
prépare pas efficacement à la
réinsertion
ce qui devrait finalement être son rôle
principal de cette manière nous sommes
conduits à une forme de fuite en avant
après les peines nous voilà instituer
des mesures post carcéral avec l'espoir
qu'elle soit efficace
là où la prison ne l'a pas été
qu'adviendra-t-il alors si celle-ci se
révéler à leur tour inefficace
faudra-t-il travailler sur un nouveau
dispositif qui permettrait un suivi
encore plus étendue à l'issue de ces
mesures
ce n'est évidemment pas la solution mais
cela nous indique une forme de précarité
face à laquelle nous devons nous montrer
vigilants dans les années à venir
toutefois ce dernier point elle
n'empêchera pas le groupe
rds de voter en faveur de cette
proposition de loi
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
j'invite à présent la présidente eliane
assassi s'exprimer au nom de son groupe
communiste pour cinq minutes présidente
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux michel collègues le 21
juillet 2020 été discuté au sénat la
proposition de loi instaurant des
mesures de sûreté à l'encontre des
auteurs d'infractions terroristes à
l'issue de leur peine adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale ne nous étions
alors fortement opposés au texte et aux
objectifs poursuivis
dans sa décision du 7 août 2020 le
conseil constitutionnel a considéré que
le dispositif retenu porter en l'état de
sa rédaction
une attente qui n'était ni adaptée ni
proportionnée aux droits et libertés
constitutionnellement garantis pourtant
les auteurs et défenseurs des
propositions de loi initiale continue à
considérer que les mesures de police
administrative administrative hull et me
casse notamment aujourd'hui privilégiée
par les autorités pour assurer et
assurer le suivi des personnes libérées
représente toujours une menace grave
pour la sécurité publique n'offrent pas
un cadre de surveillance suffisants
ainsi propose-t-il de nouveau à un
renforcement du suivi judiciaire en
proposant des garanties de réinsertion
renforcée c'est donc en toute cohérence
que la commission a approuvé le
dispositif proposé par notre président
en important que quelques ajustements
ponctuels de notre côté au groupe crc eu
notre position reste la même depuis
juillet 2020 et les censures du conseil
constitutionnel ne nous on que conforter
quant à la logique contraire à plusieurs
droits fondamentaux portés par de telles
mesures nous avons toujours été opposé
au muséum et mesures de sûreté en
général considérant qu'un individu ayant
purgé sa peine a le droit d'être
réinsérés dans notre société
rappelons que lors de l'adoption de la
rétention de sûreté le sénateur robert
badinter avait de son côté dénoncé je
cite une période sombre pour la justice
et il avait insisté sur le brouillard
dans lequel cette détention pour
dangerosité hors de toute infraction
allait plonger la justice dont les
fondements étaient atteints ces mesures
induisent à un bouleversement de la
logique même du droit pénal
en effet les mesures de sûreté ne sont
pas relative à une infraction commise
elle ne vise entre guillemets que les
états dangereux il n'existe donc pas de
faute
le but de ces mesures est en seulement
de protéger la société par des
dispositions spécifiques permettant
ainsi d'éviter notamment la récidive
on ne parle donc pas de punition mais de
prévention il s'agit notamment et dans
la plupart des cas d'utiliser ce genre
de procédures pour réadapter des
délinquants à la société par l'objet par
le biais de cure de désintoxication ou
d'internement ce qui peut déjà
grandement question présentés comme de
simples moyens prophylactiques ces
mesures peuvent présenter un danger de
dérive totalitaire or en adoptant en
adaptant les mesures de sûreté aux
personnes condamnées pour des actes
terroristes
quel message envoyons-nous en pointant
avec force la récidive probable on
envoie aux condamnés qui ont purgé leur
peine
le signal qu'ils sont suspectés avis est
en quelque sorte rejeté de la république
ne nous leurrons pas
cette justice d'exception ne se bornera
pas aux seuls cas d'aidé plus terroriste
elle fera tâche d'huile si cela n'est
déjà pas le cas au regard des lois
votées à l'encontre des auteurs de délit
et crime sexuel par exemple pourtant en
creux ce que ray lèvres révèle notamment
les mesures proposées c'est en réalité
l'échec du temps pénitentiaire et
l'épuisement d'un système basé sur le
tout carcéral
les vraies questions auxquelles ces
propositions de loi ne répond pas sont
nombreuses quels moyens pour nos
services de renseignement pour prévenir
les actes de terrorisme comment
réinsérer dans notre société des
individus condamnés pour de tels faits
les obliger pendant plusieurs années à
se rendre jusqu'à trois fois par semaine
dans un commissariat pour justifier de
leur présence est un obstacle évident à
la reprise une vie active et
socialisante questions auxquelles la
nouvelle mouture de la loi site du
gouvernement que nous examinerons ici
fin juin ne s'attache pas à répondre non
plus mes chers collègues au regard des
conséquences désastreuses sur notre
ordonnancement juridique de cette
surenchère pénale
incessantes je me demande s'il ne serait
pas sage un an avant l'élection
présidentielle de sanctuariser au
maximum notre code pénal
quoi qu'il en soit nous opposerons de
nous nous opposerons de nouveau à ce
texte qui continue selon nous malgré les
aménagements à la marge à aller à
l'encontre des principes fondamentaux de
notre état de droit en instaurant en
substance une peine après la pète
la question essentielle devrait être
comment faire en sorte que la prison
ouvre la bouche la boit
à la libération à une véritable
réinsertion et non et non comment
poursuivre la logique carcérale punitive
de réclusion en dehors des murs sur
merci merci madame la présidente
j'appelle maintenant madame nathalie
goulet à s'exprimer au nom de son groupe
union centriste pour u minutes chers
collègues
la présidente cette garde des sceaux
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois même la rapporteure bon je
mette fin au suspense nous allons voter
le texte qui nous est proposé et suivre
évidemment la décision de notre
commission
mais j'allais vous dire monsieur le
garde des sceaux pour quoi faire
la réalité c'est qu'aucun texte nous
donnera suffisamment de garanties face à
un virus mutant puisque de toute façon
la problème de la radicalise la question
de la radicalisation se pose depuis
longtemps pour y avoir travaillé dans
cette maison depuis très longtemps vous
avez sûrement le souvenir ému monsieur
le garde des sceaux que la première
question d'actualité qui vous a été
posée dans cette maison j'espère bien
elle a été par moi-même et sur le suivi
des détenus radicaliser précisément
puisque j'ai l'honneur et le privilège
d'être le sénateur
la prison de condé alençon où il ya
évidemment de nombreux problèmes avec
les détenus radicaliser et donc imbibé
des travaux de farhad koska kovar la
question de la prison demeure un
véritable sujet et si nous l'avions
suivi toutes ces années nous en serions
peut-être nous n'en serions peut-être
pas là comme beaucoup je vais vous
rappeler que la prison est un incubateur
mais vous le savez donc plus de moyens
pour les prisons plus de moyens pour la
justice plus de moyens pour la
prévention
à ce stade je voudrais aussi évidemment
rendre hommage à nos services de
sécurité au service pénitentiaire aux
services de renseignement parce qu'ils
sont un travail tout à fait remarquable
mais après le ministre darmanin s'est
exprimé cette semaine en disant qu'une
des parties
une des raisons du problème de la
sécurité c'était le manque de moyens de
la justice vous avez obtenu un bon
budget monsieur le ministre mais mais ce
navire amiral prend l'eau néanmoins il
va falloir faire mieux et j'ai tendance
à penser que le quoi qu'il en coûte
devrait être appliquée à votre ministère
pour le prochain budget dans tous les
cas nous vous soutiendrons sur cette
question qu'en est il du plan de lutte
contre la radicalisation annoncé par
edouard philippe eux le 13 juillet 2018
quelle quelle évaluation nous n'en avons
aucune et il est d'ailleurs très
intéressant monsieur le ministre que la
prod la problématique que nous examinons
maintenant va percuter le débat suivant
sur l'irresponsabilité pénale car on le
sait de nombreux détenus qualifié de
radicaliser n'ont pas leur place en
prison mais dans des hôpitaux
psychiatriques les mêmes hôpitaux qui
n'ont déjà pas les moyens de prendre
soin de leur malade on applique et reese
et le terrorisme avec des effets en
cascade des terroristes dangereux dans
le bouillon carcéral sortent plus
délinquants qu'ils ne sont rentrés les
médecins experts peu nombreux ne peuvent
jouer leur rôle
quant à la prévention elle brille par
son inefficacité et je voudrais monsieur
le ministre dresser ici pour la énième
fois un réquisitoire contre le sehy pdr
nous n'avons
pas de stratégie nous n'avons pas
d'évaluation il est quand même temps
plfr après plf est après pls nous
demandons d évaluation de ce que fait le
comité de prévention de la délinquance
et de la radicalisation nous n'avons pas
de statistiques n'avons pas de suivi et
c'est quand même extrêmement important
ça a été rappelé à plusieurs reprises
dans cette maison le travail qui avait
été fait par esther benbassa et par
catherine troendlé sur les outils la
déradicalisation ou de la lutte contre
la radicalisation ou de la
reconstruction du lien citoyen apprenez
appelons ça comme on veut
ce maillon là est aussi mon camp et nous
conduit évidemment à de très nombreuses
incertitudes donc expertise pose
problème et je vous renvoie aussi au
travail qui a été fait par notre
commission des lois et par la commission
des affaires sociales sur les failles et
les faiblesses de l'expertisé
psychiatrique
le manque d'experts la surcharge de
travail la rémunération ridicule dit si
le projet de loi de finances monsieur le
ministre il faudra regarder très
attentivement tout ce qui concerne la
lutte contre la radicalisation parce que
nous allons pouvoir voter évidemment
exposé de comme d'habitude de très
nombreuses mesures qui sont du domaine
évidemment répressif mais il reste que
la prévention est quand même une
sécurité qu'il nous faut absolument
instaurer avec des évaluations sinon
nous n'aurons pas les outils nécessaires
et puis monsieur le ministre peut-être
que d'ici
la grande loi pénale que enfin la grande
loi ce que vous êtes en train de porter
à l'assemblée nationale nous pourrions
avoir une évaluation de l'article 729 du
code de procédure pénale qui permet des
libérations conditionnelles conditions
d'expulsion ce qui serait peut-être
aussi intéressant c'est de savoir
combien de détenus dangereux ou pas
peuvent bénéficier de ce type de
disposition pour bénéficier en même
temps d'une expulsion ce qui ce qui
pourrait évidemment déplacer déplacer le
curseur du problème en tous les cas sur
toutes ces questions le sénat a toujours
été aux côtés des ministres de
l'intérieur et des ministres de la
justice qui se sont succédé à tout le
moins depuis 2015 nous avons conscience
de la question de l'unité nationale sur
les questions liées au terrorisme à la
lutte contre le terrorisme mais aussi à
toutes les questions de prévention
je crois qu'une fois encore il faut que
ces questions soient au coeur des débats
et non pas à côté
nous voterons donc le texte qui est
proposé en pensant que ce texte comme
dans d'autres vont me manquer de moyens
vont manquer de moyens humains vont
manquer de moyens financiers et c'est au
tour des moyens et de leurs ajustements
c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre
j'insiste sur les questions d'évaluation
et j'espère que nous pourrons vous
soutenir dans les textes qui vont venir
et notamment notamment financier
toujours merci
j'invite à présent monsieur henri leroy
à prendre la parole au nom du groupe
l'est républicain vous avez cinq minutes
cher collègue madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame le rapporteur mes chers collègues
rappelez vous il faut terroriser les
terroristes
voilà les mots que prononcer des gènes
notre cher et regretté charles pasqua en
1986 avant le vote des lois qui portait
son nom des rois courageuse des lois
efficaces torpiller immédiatement par
ses successeurs
nous sommes loin si loin de cette époque
où tous les responsables agissent et en
harmonie pour combat
la sécurité ç'aurait été ministre de
l'intérieur disait aussi l'insécurité
doit changer de camp et entre nous et
les terroristes
la guerre est engagée oui l'insécurité
dont doit changer de camp
oui il faut relever la police que l'on a
mis à terre
elle peut se soigner sans assurer mes
chers collègues définitivement se tenir
debout contre les terroristes
encore faut-il leur en donner les moyens
légaux aujourd'hui notre proposition de
loi n'est pas révolutionnaire
elle est est un pas un petit pas mais
elle est un pas nécessaire pour apporter
un début de soutien de solutions pardon
à cette gangrène qui le terrorise pour
notre pays instaurer une nouvelle mesure
judiciaire de suivi de surveillance post
sentenciel visant à prévenir la récidive
et à accompagner la réinsertion des
individus condamnés pour des faits de
terrorisme est une nécessité absolue
j'oserais vous rappeler quelques
chiffres sur les 269 condamnés pour
terrorisme en lien avec la mouvance
islamique suivi par le service de
l'application des peines 20% seront
suivis à leur libération dans le cadre
socio judiciaire 5% dans lé cadre d'un
sursis probatoire les 75% restants
pourront pourront bénéficier de mesures
d'accompagnement leur sortie sur la
durée des réductions de peine
éventuellement octroyées le 27 juillet
2020 le parlement a adopté une loi pour
introduire une nouvelle mesure
judiciaire de suivi de surveillance post
sentenciel envers les condamné pour les
faits de terrorisme
poursuivant ainsi deux finalités
prévenir la récidive et accompagner leur
réinsertion cette mesure a été
curieusement censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel estimant qu'elle n'était
ni adaptée ni proportionnelle objectifs
poursuivis a donc déclaré la mesure de
sûreté contraire à la constitution
proposition de loi de notre président
buffet reprend l'esprit de la loi
adoptée en juillet 2
il vint tout en y apportant des
aménagements destinés à répondre aux
cinq objections du conseil
constitutionnel je ne reviendrai pas ici
sur ces points techniques le rapporteur
muriel jourda l'a fait avec l' art et je
voudrais en revanche apporté de
précision fondamentale la première c'est
que la proposition de loi du président
du fait de notre commission des lois est
indispensable à notre ationale
judiciaire pour lutter contre le fléau
que représente la sortie des de
détention des terroristes
la seconde est républicaine je veux
lancer un appel un cri d'alarmé au
président de la république au ministre
et à vous tous mes chers collègues
l'état de droit est ce que nous avons de
plus de plus noble de plus grand en
france cet état de droit il est l'enfant
légitime de notre histoire
cet état de droit nous y sommes tous ici
profondément attaché nous le respectons
il coule dans nos veines
aujourd'hui nous n'avons non pas une
conception de sol est naïve une naïveté
qui coûtent des vies régulièrement notre
conseil constitutionnel censure des lois
des lois qui n'ont rien d'excessif fille
qui aurait pu sauver des vies parce
qu'elles sont en adéquation avec
l'extrême violence qui prospère sans
conteste à notre époque
je vous le dis haut et fort la loi doit
être conforme à la constitution
mais encore faut-il que la constitution
sera conforme à la gravité du terrorisme
aujourd'hui est ce bien le cas mais là
messieurs du gouvernement proposé un
référendum qui aura pour seul objet de
rajouter le mot développement durable
dans notre constitution est
superfétatoire et l'ambition et le
courage de proposer un vrai référendum
référendum utile pour la france et pour
les français un référendum qui porte sur
les moyens donnés à nos forces de
sécurité et un autre système pénal pour
lutter efficacement contre le terrorisme
l'urgence est indéniable je vous
remercie de m'avoir écouté
et enfin j'appelle madame thuan bora
pour les républicains pour une
intervention de quatre minutes cher
collègue madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
madame le rapporteur mes chers collègues
permettez moi de saluer la constance et
la technicité de nos commissaires aux
lois qui symbolise l'esprit d'équilibré
de responsabilité propre au sénat je le
dis à cette tribune sous le regard de
michel de l'hôpital et de françois
d'aguesseau dont la rigueur l'avait des
galas que l'esprit de tolérance c'est
parce que nous veillons à l'exécution de
peines proportionnées que nous mettons
un point d'honneur à parfaire le droit
ou à combler des carences observées jeu
renverserait un célèbre adage pour vous
dire ce que nous refusons tous ici en
matière antiterroriste agité une main de
velours dans un gant de fer
c'est dans cet esprit exigeant et
proactif que nous traitons ce jour d'une
problématique sécuritaire aux atours de
défi civilisationnel je veux bien sûr
saluer le travail de mes collègues
muriel jourda et françois noël buffet
qui animé par les exigences de l'état de
droit sont parvenus à corriger un vide
juridique particulièrement inquiétant
pour la sécurité des français
nous connaissons tous ici les chiffres
qui nous conduisent à anticiper des
sorties sèches qui nous inquiète mais
nous partageons également la conviction
qu'il faut aller plus loin et imaginer
une réforme de structure proportionnée
un phénomène que nous ne pouvons ignorer
je le dis à cette tribune comme
représentante d'un département
meurtri par l'islamisme en effet si nous
débattons avec une telle acuité du suivi
des condamnés pour terrorisme
c'est aux fins d'apporter un palliatif
aux deux enjeux qui défient l'autorité
de l'état et qu'il faudra tôt ou tard
affronter le sens de la peine et sa
proportionnalité
et la physionomie du milieu carcéral le
sens de la peine et sa proportionnalité
d'abord c'est au sénat que nous devons
l'instauration d'une peine
incompressible de 30 ans et la
limitation drastique des conditions
d'aménagements de peine il nous faut
désormais aller beaucoup plus loin
ne serait-ce qu'au regard des nouveaux
profils auquel nous avons affaire
le terrorisme est de plus en plus
juvénile son traitement pénal ne peut
l'ignorer
nous savons que les crédits de réduction
automatique seront supprimées si le
projet de loi dupond moretti est adopté
en l'état
malgré tout c'est la question de la
perpétuité réelle que nous devons
aborder car ne nous y trompons pas
l'incompressibilité ne rime pas avec
enfermement asie je rappelle que le
droit interne britannique pourtant
inspiré par l'habeas corpus et dont
personne n'oserait dire qu'ils piétinent
les droits de la défense ne permettaient
ni élargissement me réexamen des peines
de perpétuité réelle
jusqu'à ce que le juge européen néglige
la clarification d'un droit pourtant
souverain les juridictions ne doivent
pas être contraintes à offrir aux
condamnés une perspective de libération
dangereuse pour la société
deuxième à la traiter la physionomie du
milieu carcéral
l'instauration de cette perpétuité
réelle dès le prononcé paraît d'autant
plus nécessaire que la prison est
marquée par une spécificité
démographique notable selon le dernier
numéro des cahiers d'études
pénitentiaire l'âge moyen des personnes
détenues était en france environ 35 ans
soit 13 ans de moins que celle de la
population générale
les condamnés pour terrorisme n'échappe
pas à cette réalité bien au contraire il
n'est que de rappeler l'âge des cinq
derniers terroristes ayant frappé en
france pour comprendre le défi
générationnel qui est le nôtre 36 33 et
30 ans pour ceux de rambouillet charlie
hebdo et colombes 21 ans pour
l'assaillant de nice et seulement 18
pour le terroriste de conflent
mes chers collègues c'est aussi le
djihadisme d'atmosphère décrit par
gilles kepel que nous devons aujourd'hui
défier or sans suivi des détenus
terroristes relais potentiels d'une
idéologie qui croient souvent en prison
c'est notre jeunesse que nous exposons
cette proposition de loi s'attaque donc
courageusement aux dommages collatéraux
d'un phénomène qui constitue un défi
pour notre civilisation
nous traitons aujourd'hui les conseils
un mal dont il faudra très vite arracher
les racines le travail sera long car ses
racines se propage pernicieusement
jusque dans nos prisons je vous remercie
nous passons maintenant à la discussion
du texte de la commission
article 1er j'ai une demande de prise de
parole de monsieur marc philippe
daubresse
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues j'ai écouté avec
attention la discussion générale en
particulier l'intervention du garde des
sceaux et de notre collègue à la riche
en grands spécialistes ce sujet
l'année dernière j'avais soulevé le
problème du suivi des terreaux russe
sortant de prison comme rapporteur de la
loi s'ils qu'à cette occasion philippe
bas et moi avions élaboré avec plusieurs
collègues une proposition de loi dont
l'essentiel vous l'avez dit a été repris
par l'assemblée nationale puis censurée
par le conseil constitutionnel qui
néanmoins validé comme l'a dit stefano
rue de lille le principe des mesures de
sûreté et tracer le périmètre d'une
solution acceptable
constitutionnellement présentant de
nouvelles durée de nouvelles garanties
qu'on retrouve complètement dans cet
article 1er de la proposition de loi
on peut légitimement s'interroger sur
l'efficacité des me casse à l'encontre
des individus condamnés pour des faits
de terrorisme à leur sortie des tensions
c'est sûr que le ministère l'intérieur
systématiquement prenons cette mesure
alors qu' il ya encore deux ans ce
n'était que pour un tiers des des
personnes ciblées l'amica sont bien
entendu des possibilités science
renforcée mais elle présente à nos yeux
des garanties insuffisantes et elle
présente des motivations difficile à
exprimer à elle présente aussi surtout
une durée très limitée et dont la future
loi mais c'est le ministre que le
gouvernement va prenons présenté dans
son article 3 vous renforcer
singulièrement les restrictions de
liberté que vous évoquez tout à l'heure
dans les mesures administratives des me
casse en vous exposant une censure du
conseil constitutionnel puisque vous ne
suivez pas l'avis du conseil des repas
le gouvernement pas vous monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement
mais chacun sait que tous les ministres
solidaire du gouvernement
ne suit pas l'avis du conseil d'état sur
la question des me casse il y avait donc
deux solutions celle que propose le
président buffet c'est à dire de
prononcer une mesure de sûreté
répondons aux garanties au chant proposé
va présenter esquissé par le conseil
constitutionnel ou aller sur une suivre
une mesure de suivi judiciaire
vous avez raison monsieur le ministre
dira tout à l'heure que on est sur une
ligne de crête juridique et qu'il faut
éviter la superposition des mesures sauf
que qu'est ce que va faire dans la
future loi qui va nous est soumise dans
un mois à la fin du mois de juin
prévention des actes de terroristes et
les rôdeurs enseigne dans le
gouvernement il superpose une mesure me
casse avec des effets étendus à une
mesure de suivi judiciaire
nous nous pensons que la voie qui a été
choisie hier par le président barroso
lui par le président buffet des mesures
de sûreté est infiniment plus sûres
allez plus forte elle est plus efficace
allez sur constitutionnellement est allé
vite des risques d'inconstitutionnalité
qui je le redis et sera l'occasion de le
redire à la fin du mois de juin vont
sans doute se profiler pour l'article 3
de la future loi
ce que d'ailleurs n'a pas manqué de
relever tout à l'heure notre collègue le
ministre henri sarr je soutiens donc
tout à fait la logique de cette
proposition de loi initiée par notre
président françois noël buffet ladurelle
me paraît bonne
le sursis simple sa collègue par contre
la durée de notre intervention des
câbles je compris mes cheveux je pense
monsieur le ministre que nous aurons
l'occasion de reprendre ce débat d'ici
un mois et que comme le dit à l'ats
richard les camps est souhaitable de
trouver les voies d'un compromis entre
les parlementaires et le gouvernement
merci chers collègues nous commençons
par un amendement 12 rédactionnelle
monsieur le ministre quel est votre avis
favorable je vais donc aux voix
avec deux avis favorables qui votent
pour contre abstentions il est donc
adopté l'amendement 7 rectifié bis
présentée par monsieur parigi madame la
présidente monsieur le garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice madame le
rapporteur chers collègues
cette proposition de loi est présenté
comme s'inscrivant dans le cadre de la
lutte contre le terrorisme islamiste
si les auteurs de l'amendement peuvent
souscrire de manière générale à la mise
en oeuvre de mesures pour combattre ce
fléau et émettent de très grandes
réserves cela dix positions exorbitantes
du droit commun désormais trop
nombreuses qui dépassent bien souvent
leurs buts 1re en l'état le renforcement
des mesures de sûreté à destination des
terroristes islamistes
à l'issue de leur peine est trop général
tout comme le sont certains dispositions
de la loi s'ils tu es antérieurement la
création du fij est qui englobe d'autres
individus que les terroristes islamistes
les auteurs de l'amendement craignent de
facto que ce régime haddock que
s'applique notamment à des militants
politiques écologistes altermondialistes
animalistes corses basques etc ce qui
s'avérerait totalement disproportionné
par rapport à l'action militante pour
laquelle ils ont été condamnés dans ce
cas les dispositions pénales du droit
commun sont amplement suffisantes et ses
mesures de sûreté à l'issue de leur
peine apparaît très trop sévère comme
l'est d'ailleurs actuellement
l'inscription aux fillettes pour bon
nombre de ses militants c'est la raison
pour laquelle tout en réaffirmant leur
réserve de principe à ce test
les auteurs de l'amendement appel à
l'introduction à minima d'une
distinction entre les destructions
matérielles de biens et l'atteinte
volontaires à la vie humaine
ainsi cet amendement propose que les
individus condamnés pour des atteintes
aux biens soit exclu du dispositif prévu
par le présent texte et conformément au
principe général de proportionnalité
de la peine qui prévaut en droit pénal
je vous remercie
merci madame le rapporteur votre avis
s'il vous plaît merci madame la
présidente je ne porterai pas de
jugement sur la valeur du militantisme
violent je voudrais simplement indiqué
que si nous adoptions cet amendement
nous faisons perd beaucoup d'efficacité
au dispositif qui existe et qui est
prévu par cette proposition de loi
puisque ne serait plus concerné les
infractions relatives au financement du
terrorisme ou les associations de
malfaiteurs en relation avec une
entreprise terroriste
or c'est sur la base de cette
disposition
conte était prononcé un grand nombre de
condamnations concernés par ce texte je
vous propose donc de vous en tenir à la
rédaction initiale de ce texte et cette
analyse défavorable
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
sénateur paris j'ai exactement la même
analyse que celle que vient de présenter
madame la rapporteure quid de
l'association de malfaiteurs je pense qu
en droit il est compliqué de distinguer
entre toutes les éventualités vous nous
avez offerte les animalistes et les
autres et les autres et les autres jeux
j'entends bien en droit c'est une
distinction complexe et quid de
l'association malfaiteurs le texte y
perdrait en efficacité c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement y est
opposé
merci je mets aux voix cet amendement
avec deux avis défavorables qui vote
pour qui votre compte qui seul simple il
n'est pas adopté un amendement numéro 11
monsieur lévy oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame le rapporteur cet amendement il
est dur que j'ai déposée l'article
premier vise à ouvrir un peu
l'application des mesures de sûreté que
je trouve très positive toutefois mais à
mon sens c'est trop nombreuses
conditions imposées pour l'application
de ces mesures risquent de rendre ce
dispositif est inopérant ou
inapplicables dans les faits il ya
pourtant une réelle urgence si un
intérêt sécuritaire particulier à
l'application de ces mesures
cet amendement vise à supprimer la
double condition par une probabilité
très élevée de récidive et par une
adhésion persistance à une idée
j ou à des thèses incitant la commission
d'actes de terrorisme à l'une ou l'autre
des conditions pour l'application de
mesures de sûreté
il s'agit d'étendre l'application de
cette mesure je vous remercie merci
madame le rapporteur votre avis yoplait
merci madame la présidente effectivement
la proposition de loi prévoit que la
mesure de sûreté
donc des battons depuis tout à l'heure
et bien ne peut être applicable que si
l'individu présente une particulière
dangerosité caractérisée par une
probabilité très élevée de récidive et
par une adhésion persistante à une
idéologie ou à des thèses incitant la
commission d'actes de terrorisme
c'est donc ce cumul de condition que
vous voulez transformer en condition
alternative
il me semble que quel que soit le
l'opinion terroristes et le type de
terrorisme qui est visé puisque vous
résidents votre amendement le terrorisme
islamiste
de toute façon le terrorisme est
sous-tendue par une théorie et elle sera
nécessairement d'eux présente et de
surcroît je rappelle tout de même que
nous sommes ici après une censure du
conseil constitutionnel et le conseil
constitué la avait considéré que les
critères permettant de prononcer la
mesure était adaptée donc je propose que
nous les modifiant pain et c'est un avis
est défavorable ont plutôt préalablement
une demande de retrait monsieur le
ministre votre avis il me semble même la
présidente monsieur sénateurs que
l'adhésion à une idéologie seul si nous
retenions votre amendement nous ferait
encourir la censure du conseil
constitutionnel à l'évidence je suis
défavorable à votre monde
merci monsieur les filles pour retirer
il est retiré sa demande en numéro 10
messieurs les vies oui monsieur madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues c'est un moment
supprimer la condition d'application des
mesures de sûreté dans l'unique cas où
l'inscription des mentions est
suffisante sur le fichier des auteurs
d'infractions de terroristes
l'expérience de ces dernières années
nous a malheureusement démontré que trop
souvent des personnes pouvaient être
inscrits sur des fichiers avait peu de
mention et par conséquent considéré
comme non dangereuses alors que
en réalité une dangerosité certaines
toujours merci merci beaucoup madame le
rapporteur votre avis sur cette
suppression d'un mineur merci mr le
président il s'avère qu'une des
conditions posées par le conseil
constitutionnel et que la mesure de
sûreté ne soit que subsidiaire par
rapport aux autres mesures qui existent
et c'est pour cela que cette mesure a
été également comprises dans les mesures
qui peuvent être prononcées et qui
justifierait si elles sont très
approprié que une mesure de sûreté ne
soit pas prononcé donc il me paraît
difficile sans en cours et à nouveau les
foudres du conseil constitutionnel de
nous passer de cette mesure car nous
nous passerions de la subsidiarité qui
était une des conditions c'est donc un
avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre idem
monsieur lévy vous retirer il est donc
retiré nous passons à l'amendement
premier rectifié terres exposées par
madame bord qui au fond teinte s'il vous
plaît rompant madame la présidente
madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues le niveau de risque de
récidive est à la fois le corollaire est
la conséquence de la dangerosité des
individus condamnés pour actes de
terrorisme face à cette aide meurtrière
pour ce que nous sommes des citoyens
libres et éclairés et bien la plus
grande rigueur de tête de mise
cette proposition marque donc une
avancée indéniable dans cette reconquête
de fermeté de crédibilité dans cette
ligne droite cet amendement propose de
compléter la nuit à l'alinéa 18 en
introduisant une référence explicite au
niveau de risque de récidive
merci madame le rapporteur votre avis
ainsi même le président les choses vont
sans dire ils vont encore me en dix ans
et à l'amendement de précision qui me
paraît utile et c'est un avis favorable
monsieur le ministre quel est votre avis
sur cette modification d'alinéa 18
je sollicite le registre est tellement
de noms parce que je pense que l'objet
en est déjà satisfait justement 90 ans a
précisé que la commission
pluridisciplinaire des mesures de sûreté
droite également évaluer le niveau de
risque de la personne
outre sa dangerosité
je rappelle que la mesure de chanter ne
sera appliqué le cas des personnes qui
présentent une particulière dangerosité
et le texte précise que cette dernière
devrait être caractérisée par une
probabilité très élevée de récidive et
par une adhésion persistante à une
idéologie ou à des thèses incitant à la
commission d'actes de terrorisme il est
par conséquent inutile de préciser à
nouveau que l'évaluation de la personne
devra permettre de définir le niveau de
ce risque
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux
je mets donc on voit cet amendement
premier rectifié terre avec un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui s'abstient il était
adopté un amendement de rectifier bis
madame bord qui au fond de teint
cette proposition de loi expose donc
clairement son objectif c'est à dire
garantir la sécurité de nos concitoyens
en permettant à la justice de mieux
surveiller ces individus et d'adapter
donc en conséquence les sanctions en
fonction de l'importance
l'importante dangerosité qui les
caractérisent cet amendement vise à
porter à huit semaines
le placement du détenu dans un service
spécialisé chargé de leurs observations
face au risque indéniable de récidive de
ces individus il est donc impérieux de
permettre aux agents de ce service de
bénéficier d'un temps d'observation et
d'études plus conséquent et ce afin de
mener leur travail d' expertise dans les
meilleures conditions
cet amendement vise donc à garantir que
la durée d'observation soit porté un
délai raisonnable afin que nos
institutions puissent protéger au mieux
les français et désire meurtrier de ces
individus merci madame le rapporteur
votre avis merci à la présidente
nous sommes d'accord évidemment sur la
nécessité d'une évaluation efficace de
la dangerosité des détenus qui vont
sortir de détention
néanmoins je trop observer que la durée
de six semaines est une durée minimale
et non pas une durée maximale de sorte
que dans les fêtes
elle peut excéder cette durée de six
semaines et de surcroît lors de nos
auditions
nous n'avons entendu personne déploré la
durée qui avaient été fixés par par le
texte je vous propose de vous en tenir
aux textes qui existent et c'est une
demande de retrait des fois un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre même position
pour le gouvernement madame la
présidente
notre hills je mets donc aux voix vous
retirer vous retirer il est retiré
l'amendement numéro 9 présenté par
monsieur lévy oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président la commission des lois madame
le rapporteur mes chers collègues cet
amendement vise à supprimer la condition
d'application des mesures de sûreté au
fait que le détenu ait pu bénéficier de
façon effective des mesures de
réinsertion dans le cadre de sa
détention en intégrant sa disposition
c'est une imitation de plus qui peut
avoir une fille née des conséquences
sécuritaires car du fait d'une
défaillance de l'administration
pénitentiaire qui parfois par manque de
moyens de personnel ne peut offrir un
programme de réinsertion à tous les
détenus
il convient donc de supprimer cette
condition supplémentaire je vous
remercie
merci madame le rapporteur merci le
président j'entends bien ce souci
d'efficacité monsieur lévy mais je
crains fort de ne pas vous être très
agréable ou du manque de conseil
constitutionnel ne vous soit pas très
agréable tant la réalité c'est le
conseil constitutionnel qui a fixé comme
condition le fait que cette mesure de
sûreté puissent être mises en oeuvre
dans la mesure où le détenu avait pu
bénéficier de mesures de réinsertion
je me suis posé la même question que
celle que vous êtes posé et nous avons
interrogé les services compétents
il n'y a pas de difficultés aujourd'hui
pour mettre en oeuvre ces mesures de
réinsertion
pendant la détention de sorte que non
seulement nous devons me semble-t-il
conserver cette condition puisque nous
revenons après censure du conseil
constitutionnel qu'il faut donc se
conformer à la censure si je puis dire
mais de surcroît cette mesure peut être
appliquée actuellement donc ça ne me
semble pas poser de difficultés c'est
donc une demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre s'il vous
plaît votre avis oui je rappelais
simplement j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans
mon discours qu'il existe aujourd'hui
les quartiers d'évaluation de l'arabie
alisation et des quartiers de prise en
charge et dans le quartier de prise en
charge évidemment il ya tout un
programme qui tend à la réinsertion qui
mise en oeuvre de plus en plus
fréquemment bien sûr enfin dès qu on a
décelé le potentiel de dangerosité et la
radicalisation
puis je rappelle par ailleurs que c'est
une condition qui nous est rappelé par
le conseil constitutionnel
et je crains que si votre amendement été
retenue nous repartions si j'ose dire
pour un tour et nous perdions en réalité
beaucoup de temps merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur lévy vous retirer
l'amendement trois listes présentées par
madame bord qui au foot à cet amendement
vise à permettre d' ordonner la mise en
place de cette mesure de sûreté pour une
durée maximale de deux ans ces individus
ont commis des actes visant à détruire
la république faire tomber nos
institutions est assassiné lâchement nos
concitoyens les académiques ou encore
des journalistes ont mené l enquête pour
comprendre les phénomènes de
radicalisation et de déradicalisation
beaucoup ont attesté du caractère
presque irréversible du premier est
prévenue des difficultés induites par le
second l'une d'entre elles était à
nouveau le temps d'observation mais
aussi de surveillance donc bien que la
mesure initiale de durée maximale d'un
an puissent être renouvelés
elle demeure en l'état difficilement
compris c'est donc accepté par une
majorité de nos concitoyens
merci madame le rapporteur merci madame
la présidente
ce débat nous l'avons déjà eu lorsque
madame jacqueline eustache brinio été
rapporteur du texte qui a été censuré
par le conseil constitutionnel
un accord a été trouvé avec l'assemblée
nationale pour fixer la durée de cette
mesure de sûreté à un an dans la mesure
où le texte qui a été déposée a pour but
de répondre à la censure du conseil
constitutionnel mais pas de modifier
l'architecturé de ce qui avait été mise
en place
je vous propose de retirer cet
amendement à défaut ce serait un avis
défavorable
tu voulais très bien monsieur ministre
même position vous retirer il est retiré
l'amendement 4 rectifié bis madame board
qui au fond temps si vous voulez nous le
pré
on peut pas le dernier malgré le travail
titanesque abattu les magistrats ne
peuvent pas toujours les délais de tenir
les délais disposés par les textes
cet amendement proposant de porter le
délai à six mois la juridiction
régionale de la rétention de sûreté doit
pouvoir bénéficier d'un délire
raisonnable afin de confirmer ou non le
maintien des obligations visées par à 7
elle est née à 31 même le rapporteur
merci le président nous serons dans une
situation où une mesure a été prononcé
mais où elle a été suspendue par une
détention pour d'autres faits de la
personne concernée par cette mesure
dans ces conditions à l'issue de cette
détention dans un délai de trois mois
une mesure doit être prise par une
juridiction pour poursuivre la mesure de
sûreté ou pour l'arrêter porter ce délai
à 6 mois me semble difficile car en
réalité ce sont des mesures
attentatoires aux libertés qui sont
prises dans le cas de la mesure de
sûreté est une juridiction d'un statut
et le plus rapidement possible pour
pouvoir poursuivre ou ne pas poursuivre
ses mesures de sorte que c'est une
demande de retrait ou à défaut un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre mais ma vie
même position vous retirer il est retiré
je mets donc aux voix l'article 1er qui
votent pour contre abstentions il est
donc adopté jamais se voit l'article 2
qui votent pour contre abstentions il
est adopté l'article 3 qui votent pour
contre abstentions il est adopté
nous abordons un article additionnel
après l'article 3
avec l'amendement numéro 5 qui
présentait par madame benbassa merci
madame la présidente
il est fondamental pour garantir la
sûreté la sécurité des citoyens de
prévenir toute sortie sèche de détenus
radicaliser aucune mesure relative à la
prévention n'est présente dans cette ppl
qui propose surtout une série de mesures
de sûreté dont l'utilité n'aura que peu
d'effet sur le degré de
10 qualité de la personne au cours des
prochaines années
nous estimons qu'en matière de lutte
contre la radicalisation islamiste
il est important de ne pas avoir une
approche fondée uniquement sur la
surveillance le temps de la détention
doit être mis à profit pour prévenir la
récidive
accompagné de la déradicalisation poire
le désengagement
ainsi pour faire écho au rapport
sénatorial sur la radicalisation
publiant 2017
quelques j'ai eu l'honneur de corps à
porter avec madame catherine tremblay le
groupe écologie solidarité territoire
demande au gouvernement de remettre au
parlement dans un délai de 12 mois à
compter de la promulgation de la
présente loi
un rapport sur l'accès aux activités de
réinsertion des personnes détenues mise
en cause dans des affaires de terrorisme
islamiste ussel écrouées pour des faits
de droits communs repérer par
l'administration et par les services de
l'enseignement comme étant susceptible
de la dic alisation je vous remercie
merci chers collègues malades
le rapporteur pardon votre vie walesa
vallée madame la présidente je remercie
mon avis va être défavorable alors une
demande de retrait madame benbassa vous
connaissez la position traditionnelle de
la commission des lois qui une position
qui est juridiquement étayé et qui
consiste à dire que non seulement nous
ne pourrons pas donné d'instructions
gouvernement mais durent se croient nous
disposons nous mêmes de moyens
d'évaluation qui nous permettent de
présenter des rapports et c'est
d'ailleurs de votre propre rapport avec
madame trot attelé que
vous parlez lorsque vous indiquez dans
cet amendement souhaité savoir ce qu'il
en est alors je pense qu'effectivement
je parle sous le contrôle de monsieur le
président buffet président de la
commission des lois un rapport sur le
sujet peut toujours être possible et il
y a eu un rapport qui a été rendu par
une autorité ou du moins un organisme
indépendant l'ifri très récent de
février 2021 que vous avez peut-être lu
avec intérêt puisqu'il cite le rapport
du sénat dont vous êtes l'auteur avec
madame trônent les donc selon je dirais
la jurisprudence habituelle de la
commission des lois
c'est un âne demande de retrait ou un
avis est défavorable sur cette demande
de rapport monsieur le ministre votre
avis sur cet amendement s'il vous plaît
merci bien la présidente madame la
sénatrice même basse en réalité le
gouvernement pour tout vous dire n'est
pas très favorable à la multiplication
des rapports le parlement le monde à ce
point de vue dispose déjà de de
multiples moyens d'information et
contrôle de l'activité du gouvernement
et dans ces conditions je suis contraint
de vous dire que je suis défavorable à
l'amendement que vous présentez même la
sénatrice merci madame benbassa jamais
on vous voit avec deux avis défavorables
qui votent pour contre abstentions il
n'est pas adopté je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi y at
il des demandes d'explications de vote
je n'en vois pas je mets donc aux voix
qui votent pour
qui vote contre qui s'abstient cette
proposition de loi est adopté
[Musique]